Um, Fared. Oh, I hope it's the Fared
that we know.
It's not. Trust me, it's not.
Right. How you doing?
Hello, guys. This is so good.
Okay, finally I'm here.
Love the impression, guys.
What's up, how you doing for?
I'm doing good. How are you guys?
Yeah, we're good.
All right, that's nice. So, um I just I
just I'm not very familiar with the
Islamic dilemma argument. Like, I know
bits and parts of it. Like uh the basic
premise is that Quran affirms the Bible
and if the Bible is true that means the
Quran is false because it contradicts
the Bible and if the Bible is false that
means the Quran is false for confirming
the Bible. But can I have like the
verses you guys are talking about like
mainly just like the main verses you
guys used so I can
Yeah. So you you just want us to list a
bunch for you and you can jot them down
and look at them or
Yeah. Yeah. That's basically that's what
I'm trying to do.
Yeah. So uh chapter 3:es 3 to 4 surah
3:es 3 to 4 that talks about the
inspiration of the Torah and the gospel
Allah sending it down revealing it so on
um then you have 757 surah 7 verse 157
that talks about Jews and Christians
reading the Torah and the gospel that
are written down with them five surah 5
43 to 48 very important uh passage verse
43en 43
then 37 then you you got the Christians
and then 48 then it's the Quran
affirming the previous scriptures. So
you have those also verses uh 66 and 68
of surah 5. So surah 5 66 and 68
um 1094 surah 10 verse 94 is one Avery
likes to bring up about uh Allah telling
Muhammad that hey if you have doubts go
to the people of the book make sure your
revelations line up with uh theirs. So
that's
they're reading they're reading it. So
yeah,
so that's 1094. And then in surah 2,
surah 2 is just basically stacked with
passages. But
yeah, I understand 79 85 I think 81 41.
Yeah, things like that.
Yeah, 40. Yeah, 40 to 44 is good
passage. And you mentioned the others.
Um,
uh, yeah, 85
uh 85, 91, 97, 101. Bunch of bunch of
good passages there. But you you get
this you get this overall pattern that
emerges that what the Quran is saying is
not hey Jews and Christians your
scriptures have been corrupted therefore
go to the Quran. It's that Allah has
revealed different books to different
groups and you're what you're
responsible for is following the
revelation that was given to your group.
But it's just like it's taken for
granted that these revelations all match
up somehow. But eventually people looked
at the revelations that hey these don't
match up. And so that's when people
started having to say oh your your
scriptures have been corrupted when
that's not what the Quran says. But
basically they realized that these books
don't line up with uh with the Quran and
therefore they had to throw them out.
Problem is the Quran didn't say they're
corrupted. The the Quran affirmed the
their inspiration the preservation
authority of scriptures that contradict
the Quran. And so that's the that's the
basis for the Islamic dilemma.
Okay. Hey, by the way, just for your
notes, if you can just add it as well,
18 verse 27.
All right.
And then 614 and 115.
Thank you.
Yep.
Oh, and and you and you also you also
have uh you also have some interesting
uh hadiths. Uh you've got a hadith in
Jam Turdy where Muhammad says that Jews
and Christians still have the Torah and
the Gospel. And it says that they have
it in the same the same way that that
Muslims still have the Quran, which
wouldn't make sense if Jews and
Christians had a corrupt uh Torah and
gospel. And then in Sunn Abu Daw, you
have the historical background of 543
where he tells the Jews to bring him a
copy of the Torah. And he says, "I
believe in you and the one who revealed
you." So you put it all together and
it's almost like how much clearer can
Allah and Muhammad make their position
on this? It's like what what could they
possibly say to affirm our scriptures
more than they are more than they've
already said? It's like they they it's
like they're affirming it in every
possible different way they can. It's
like they're responding to Muslim
objections ahead of time. It's like
Muslims say, "Oh, it's just affirming
the original Torren Gospel." No, that's
why he repeatedly says, "Affirming what
you still have." So, it's like it the
Quran contains responses to all the uh
claims Muslims make about corruption.
So, it's just interesting,
right? Okay. So, uh is that all or
should I write more notes?
That that'll give you the main idea.
Again, there there are hundreds.
Yeah. So, could you guys like I don't
know teach me about the Islamic dilemma
or like I don't know give me more
details or like anything else like I
don't know maybe explain some of the
verses like uh I know that I think Dosei
speaks Arabic very well.
Uhhuh. So,
um
you want to go through a verse and we go
through it together maybe?
Yeah, I think I think that's I think
that sounds good. Yeah, maybe like one
or two Why don't you pick one from the
list and we'll uh we'll bring it up and
share the commentaries and stuff.
All right. So maybe three three to four.
Chapter 3 versus 3 to 4.
Perfect. Uh let me find it first. Okay.
And then I'm going to ask Joy to put it
on the screen.
No. Three over 3 to four. Yeah.
Okay. Okay.
Okay. We got it.
Okay. All right. Let me um let's just
put on the screen.
I don't have it on right now, so is it
okay if you guys just read it for me?
Yeah. Yeah, we'll put on the screen for
you and I'll go through the Arabic with
you. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Thank you.
No problem.
Okay. You know Arabia?
No, I don't speak Arabic.
Okay. Okay. So,
I cannot read though, so it's it's
okay. Yeah,
it's okay. We'll go through it with
everyone then. So, surah 3:3 says, "He
has sent down upon you the book in truth
confirming what was before it." The
Arabic is
so means it's his hands. So, he's
confirming what is between his hands.
And then he says, "And he revealed the
Torah and the gospel."
Right? I've read somewhere that he means
like some sort of idiom like like it
doesn't literally mean
it can it can mean like what's in your
possession what's with you like what not
not literally in your hands but like you
have it like you have it in your house
or you have it with you somewhere
you have access to it or something
in other words it it would actually be
an interesting parallel to all the Quran
verses that say confirming what is with
you confirming what you have it it's a
it would be another way of saying that
confirming what's in your like between
your hands or in your present or
something like that,
right? Okay. Thank you.
Okay. Yeah. Go on.
Uh yeah. Yeah. Just if you can explain
the taps, your honor right now.
Yeah. So, this is the taps. It's he's
talk it's talking about um meaning that
with truthfulness regarding that in
which the people of the Torah and the
gospel differed. Okay.
Right.
Uh regarding and he mentions the people
actually meaning the um the people of
Najaran, the Christians of Najaran.
Right.
Okay. Um and then it says confirming
what is between his hands. Meaning the
Quran confirming what came before it of
the books of Allah.
Right?
Okay. That's what the says in this.
Okay. Next verse.
So the next verse before meaning what
came before as guidance for the people
and he revealed uh actually says he's
revealed alan. Um that's what it says in
the Arabic and alan
is a book that any book from Allah.
That's what Nab says.
Okay. And um here he says the thing the
same thing again. He revealed the
decisive judgment between truth and
falsehood
um in that which the factions and the
people of religions differed regarding
the matter of Isa Jesus and others. Um
and then he he he says what means which
making distinction between truth and
falsehood. Um but that like we said n
said that that book can be any book from
Allah.
Yeah. Yeah.
All right.
Does it could it be that the the context
mainly like points towards that the
foran at this time is the Quran and it's
not the Torah and the maybe in this time
in the context
it it could be but we know that it could
be any other book
and and the point of the is not to judge
between the books of Allah but it's just
to be like it says here just between
falsehood and truth in general. So you
have a lot of people talking about Jesus
for example like regarding the matter of
Jesus and it's saying this is going to
let you know like what's true and false
not between the books but but between
like what people are saying
maybe maybe we can find that um I think
when where was that um yeah we'll just
get you the um
we'll just get youn3
yeah the word
we're just going to have to scroll up a
little bit this document is not uh
easily searchable not yet but it's in 2
verse 53. Uh, and we'll Okay, we're
getting closer. Okay,
right here.
So, yeah, said
Abbas said the word, okay, the criterion
is the comprehensive name for the Torah,
the gospel, the Psalms, and als
all all the books,
all of it. Right. So they're not they're
not criterians amongst themselves like
like the Quran is not the criterion for
the gospel or the gospel is not the
criterion for the Torah. It's saying all
these books are the like as a whole
collectively are the criterion.
The same way Allah uses the word
sometimes he uses it for the Quran
sometimes he uses it for
like the people of the book the people
of the
Yeah. Exactly. So it's not that one book
is and the rest are not not good enough.
That's not how that's not what it is.
And by the way, just uh just for your
like for your out of like for your
notes, maybe this might be interesting
to you. Uh this is a graph here that we
made and it lists all
Yeah, exactly.
Okay.
About there's 19 times in total, but it
comes across 18 verses. 18 verses, but
19 times in total. Um but specifically
Madhan in the context of like the the
books because you do have this word
appearing for um John the Baptist where
it says he's confirming
like the word from the like meaning
Jesus he's confirming Jesus. So just
like John the Baptist confirms Jesus
these are also confir like the Quran
also confirms the Bible. So that you do
find it used another time like for other
things. But this is this is all the
references when it's relating to the
books of Allah that are being confirmed
by the Quran.
Okay. Okay. But I also have a question
that you can screenshot that if you
want.
Yeah. Yeah. All right. Um I I have most
of the verses that it's talking about
here
like 33 546 and 548 things like that.
Okay.
And where it also mentions confirmation.
But I have a question regarding the the
Bible where it's uh specifically the New
Testament where it says Matthew 23 1-3.
Matthew 23.
Okay. Oh yeah.
And I heard this argument that I don't
know if it's true or not, but it says
that um the word confirming here could
be like a general confirmation over the
the the scriptures that they have. Uh
just like uh Jesus here is giving a
general confirmation on what um the oral
law like what the Pharisees teach them
like obey everything they tell you.
Yeah, it's it's not a general
confirmation. Yeah, we're referring with
the argument. We're fingering with the
Muslims who raise it. But um what is
that? You're do you honestly think that
that's what it's saying or like
explain it to me because I'm not very
well versed in this.
Yeah. No, there's no problem. So there's
basically four different ways that you
can take it. So like what first of all,
what the question is like what is Moses'
seat or what is the seat of Moses? Okay.
So the first way you can take it is like
uh that it was in like an actual like
piece of furniture in the synagogue
which is like the authoritative
interpretation of the Torah like like uh
like the interpretation sat on the seat
of Moses like you know the interpreter
is there. Okay, that's one like it's
actually historical thing. Another one
is that it's just like a metaphor that
the Pharisees they assumed this like
role of being the the interpreter of the
Torah.
So that's the seat of Moses means you're
interpreting the Torah. Okay.
Right.
Um and then there's a third one which
can be the seat of Moses is um like a a
specific chair that was used to put the
Torah scrolls on. Right? So like when
the synagogue when the synagogue is not
in service, this scroll, the Torah
scroll would literally be sitting in the
seat of Moses,
right? Yeah. That's one interpretation,
right?
Yeah. And then the other the the the
final one is that it just refers to like
the Pharisees like position um in terms
of like they they're the ones who
basically had access to the Torah. So
they were in the seat of Moses because
they had access to the Torah. So, at no
point is it saying that you're to follow
their interpretations of the because,
you know, if you if you think that
that's really what it's saying, you're
going to have to you have so many
problems because Jesus is continually
continuously like disagreeing with their
interpretations and correcting them on
certain things. So, that can't be what
it's saying, right? Cuz you want to be
as charitable as possible, right? you
want to be as like when we go through
the the Quran and we're going through
all the commentaries, we're literally
looking at all the commentaries and
we're noting anytime there's something
against us, we're still noting it down
and we're like weighing out all the
evidence to see what is the Quran really
saying here based on all the
commentaries. So if you want to be as
charitable as possible. So the most
charitable interpretation is that Jesus
is not contradicting himself earlier on
when he's disagreeing with the Pharisees
interpretation and he's challenging them
and correcting them. So it's it's you
know Yeah. So I hope that hopefully that
that makes sense. So he's not saying
like
that doesn't make sense.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Cool.
But could it be used in the same light
when the Quran is confirming the the
scriptures that they have between their
hands?
You have to if you're going to say that
it means something opposite to
Yeah. I would have to look at the Yeah.
the the
but if but even the is on on our side on
in this is really obvious that what they
had at the time the Torah and the gospel
whatever they had at the time is you
know comes from like I confirm it I
believe it
right so if you're going to come out
with a different conclusion that it's
corrupted or something else you're very
dangerous because it's going against the
obvious meaning you need like very good
evidence you need another verse or some
other passage that says Yeah, but they
got this bit wrong. And in the whole
Quran, I've read it many times. Many,
many times. Nowhere does it say some of
their books are good and and the rest
are corrupt.
Yeah.
Never. Not even in the taps where it
actually says like um they came to
Muhammad with this problem. Like the
Jews in like in surah 5 43 to 47, the
Jews came with not judge by their own
Torah. Yeah.
It says go judge by the Torah. Why are
they coming to you?
Yeah. Now, you have to say that this
means the whole Torah is good because it
didn't say go to that part and not the
other part of the Torah. So, you have to
have very good evidence that's opposite
to what the verse is actually saying.
Otherwise, you're going against Allah.
And so, yeah, like and so back to like
Matthew 23 though, if you like just keep
reading and uh you know Jesus is saying
like they're telling you to call them
rabbi, rabbi. So, if if the
interpretation is okay, whatever the
Pharisees say, well, Jesus is saying you
have to follow exactly what they say.
But then he literally goes on the very
next sentence and says they say rabbi
rabbi and he's saying don't do that
don't be calling rabbi rabbi because you
only have one master you have one and
that's me the Christ the Messiah. So,
like I said, you have to get the most
charitable interpretation and he's not
is unless you want to say that he's
contradicting himself in the very next
sentence, right? Cuz he's literally
challenging what they say, right? So, so
you know, it's like whatever they're
interpreting of the Torah, that's the
correct interpretation. Go by that, but
don't do what they do. Do what they're
saying about the Torah, but don't do
what they do. And all of this stuff that
like, you know, like about the Talmud
and the Mishna and these these come
these come much much later. So if you
have the Muslims telling you, "Oh, Jesus
is, you know, verifying everything that
the Pharisees and the scribes did and
they're pointing you to like the tal the
Mishna or the Talmud or whatever and
they're saying, "Oh, look what they said
here." Well, that's much much later. And
we don't have I mean, the evidence is
not strong that everything that these
things said it goes back to the first
century. Some of the things Yeah, you
can say some of them went back to the
first century. Not everything that they
said. So you can't judge on a book
that's like, you know, 300 years later
or 600 years later and say, "Oh, that's
what the Pharisees were saying in the
first century." Right? So, so yeah, your
Muslim the Muslims were telling you
this, they'd be hardressed to give you
documentation in the first century for
what exactly what exactly were the
Pharisees saying. And if if if what
they're saying is correct, follow what
the Pharisees say, but don't do what
they do. Well, what exactly were the
Pharisees saying? You know, the Muslims
are they're going to tell you like, "Oh,
go look at the Talmud." That comes much
much later. How do you know that's what
they were saying in the first century?
So there's a lot of leaps you have to
take and like I said the most charitable
interpretation and like literally the
next verse he says they say this but
don't say what they say don't do that
either. So it just seems to make you
know the most like the one that makes
the most sense is when it comes to
interpreting the Torah the most correct
interpretation the correct
interpretation that they give follow
that but don't do the things that they
do. Right. Yeah. So there's not a
parallel here to the Islamic dilemma.
Yeah, like I said, we're familiar with
these arguments like we've hear it from
the Muslims and it's it's it's like
they're trying to get out of it, but
it's it's also kind of like a what
aboutism as well. So, even if let's say
even if that's a true dilemma, let's
just say if it is for the Christians, it
doesn't it doesn't help the Muslims
escape from their dilemma, right?
And you can see how
you have to and you see how desperate it
is. They're going to a a place where
Jesus calls out the Pharisees for their
hypocrisy. He's saying, "Do what they
say, which is from the Torah, but not
what they do." Because they're
hypocrites. They go they they go against
what they preach in what they do.
I don't see how that helps the Islam
Muslim dilemma where it's actually Allah
versus Muslims.
Yeah.
It's actually Allah saying go to the
Torah, go to the gospel. It believes
what I'm telling you and then you guys
say it's corrupt. That's like the whole
opposite of what you're Allah saying,
right?
Make sense?
Yeah, it does. Your explanations are
very good. Thank you.
Okay, great. Sure.
All right. I think I'm just going to
have to have to go now.
Okay. Hey, it's on my own research.
Yeah. talking to you. It's really good
talking to you.
Thank you. It was good talking to you
guys, too.
All right.
Hey, Dilemma. Do you remember me?
No, I I I don't, man. What What were we
talking about?
Same topic.
Same topic. Two two weeks ago on a
Wednesday.
Monday. Sorry. Monday.
You You got a good memory, bro. I would
have to I would have to get it, you
know.
No, it's because you deal with like tens
dozens of people, so I understand why.
Anyway,
it's all good, though.
Yeah. I hope I talk to you later soon,
too.
Yeah. Yeah. Come, come anytime, man. I
said I probably said that to you last
time. Huh? Come anytime.
You did. You did.
Yeah, cuz because we had a good
conversation.
Yep.
All right. Yeah, it's starting to ring a
bell now. Yep.
Have a good day, everybody.
All right. Take care, bro.
You, too.
God bless you, man. Hey, hey, hey,
Avery, you gota you got to learn uh you
got to learn that line from the Street
Fighter movie, man. When uh she comes
and she gives this speech about how he
like destroyed killed her family and
destroyed her village all these years
ago. And uh she gives this awesome
speech that she'd been preparing since
she was a child. And he says, "Uh, I
don't remember any of this. I understand
the day that Bison graced you with his
presence was the most important day of
your life, but for me it was Tuesday."
Got to learn that one.